إنني أدين حماس بشكل لا لبس فيه، وذلك حتى
يتمكن كل شخص في الغرفة من فهم
أنني أقف إلى جانب المدنيين
والبراءة وليس إلى جانب
المواقف السياسية. كانت هجمات 7 أكتوبر
بربرية، كيف يمكنني أن أصفها بأنها
كانت مروعة، لقد استخدموها  لقد كانوا
عشوائيين، لقد قتلوا النساء
والأطفال وكبار السن، لا يهم لقد
ضربوا المؤسسات المدنية وضربوا
أهدافًا عسكرية، وفوق كل ذلك،
يبدو أنه لا بأس الآن في الاستيلاء على الرهائن
وأخذهم والتحدث عن ذلك كما لو
كان عملاً من أعمال الحرب.  وهذا شيء
ندينه وقد أدانناه في
التاسع من تشرين الأول/أكتوبر على ما أعتقد أو الثامن الآن
إسرائيل. أدين بشكل لا لبس فيه
الحملة الجوية التي أسفرت عن مقتل
أكثر من
11,000 شخص في غزة،
منهم 4,700 طفل الآن وقد
أدى كلا هذين العملين إلى  موت
الأبرياء، كلا هذين الفعلين لم
ينقذ البشرية جمعاء، وهما في
الواقع يعادلان قتل
البشرية جمعاء، كلاهما مستهجن، كلاهما
يجب أن
يتوقفا.